FIRST, MORE CONGRATS TO BRET ON
TEN YEARS ANCHORING
"SPECIAL REPORT" ."
>> HEY, BRET BAIER.
IT'S YOUR FAVORITE HOUR BEFORE
YOURS, "THE FIVE."
>> THE ONLY HOUR BEFORE YOURS.
>> ALSO THE FAVORITE.
CONGRATULATIONS ON TEN YEARS.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN INVITED TO BE
A GUEST ON YOUR ALL-STAR PANEL.
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE IT
PERSONALLY.
HOPEFULLY TEN YEARS FROM NOW,
MAYBE I WILL MAKE IT.
>> IVER NUMBER 15 YEARS AGO WHEN
YOU RUSHED UP FROM ATLANTA TO
HELP WITH 9/11 COVERAGE AND EVER
SINCE THEN, YOU HAVE BEEN LIKE A
ROCK AND WE SO APPRECIATE
"SPECIAL REPORT."
I HAVE BEEN ON THE PANEL, JESSE.
>> THANKS FOR RUBBING IT IN.
>> RATIONALITY COUNTS.
>> THAT HURTS.
>> HAPPY ANNIVERSARY.
IT'S ONE OF THE HONORS OF MY
CAREER TO BE ON YOUR PANEL.
SORRY, JESSE.
I LOVE IT.
THANK YOU.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS ON THE
PANEL.
>> BECAUSE HE IS A GOOD EGG, WE
HAVE GREG.
>> NICE!
THE ONLY PERSON NOT ON THE PANEL